good morning Millenia good morning
Millennials welcome to the morning toast
today is October 1st 2008 I really I
found that the episode where it all
started because we have a lot of new
listeners who might not be in tuned
mitts like this inside joke and I want
everyone to feel included so hopefully
everyone did their homework and watch a
six-minute video I post it on our
Facebook page and are therefore in tune
with what the significance of today is
and I just feel like I'm like so much
has changed for me like I still really
need the $200 yeah and like I just think
it was like inconsiderate time cuz like
you ain't just playing a wedding no and
I was like in the process of planning
that new son exactly and like I just had
a lot of expenses that I really needed
that $20 for and people when they come
to my shows they ask me all the time
like did you ever get it back and like
it's just a true story I'm like this is
a completely true story I never got the
$200 back um and I used to call him
every couple months just like to remind
him that I existed but I thought that
was annoying and I was getting nowhere
but today I thought it would still be
even more special if we called him live
on air also it's been a year he owes you
interest okay what is my interest rate
interest rate currently Margo look it up
will be fair like we're like a bank even
though like it is a personal loan so you
can charge whatever the [ __ ] you want
right also it depends to see if he's
Jewish because it is in the Torah that
Jewish people are not allowed to charge
interest to other Jewish people no just
like in general well is Miranda Jewish
last name oh four percent sigh point oh
four is that like every year okay so he
owes you about two hundred and ten
dollars and 80 cents should I request it
interest mom or just like take what I
can get I mean you're gonna get nothing
either way I'm like so nervous to call
him to do it now at least was the
origination of the pit remember when you
showed out them so what happened was you
showed us everything up with the word
pit no no we came up with the word peed
on that I'm sorry but this is how we
introduced during the show who came up
with the word pit when that woman like
left a pit on your couch no when that
woman slept on my couch and then later
of them gave me a pit like not cool you
had such on my couch but now you're
giving me pits we were in a blender how
do our saving lives I don't get it I
know we had spoken about pits on the
show the day before and then you came on
the show the next day you're like what's
so funny we talk about pits and now I
have one give birth to one right and
it's Costin yeah and so it was so I'm
gonna call him try do it now great like
so nervous and also like this is gonna
be the longest show ever because there's
so much to address so much to address
our sister got engaged I met Andy Cohen
Anthony Vasquez is here and we end it's
October 1st and it's October 1st so it's
national morning to assay which means
this show should be three hours right
yeah I'm sorry honey baskets you're
gonna have to sit here for an hour while
we'd just shoot the [ __ ] and then we'll
get to share the wedding I hope you
didn't have other plans
yes I'll be Rama D weddings today okay
so I feel like I call him from my phone
he definitely has me like listen okay I
want to go from your phone but have we
ever called from your phone before never
a banner I checked this morning to make
sure I still had his phone number and
honestly he's not that technologically
savvy even if we had call from my cell
number it's not like his ringtone is its
Derek Smeath
right not answer this call its Derek
Smeath by the way it's so funny I go to
look for his number in my phone it's
literally saved star six seven six
horses that's so will you start six
seven just a course of action oh you
have a better chance of him picking up
when it's like oh he just thinks it
could be someone from some area right
okay so let me type it in
I'm so nervous like I'm freaking do my
feelings I'm gonna die on today's show
but you know okay it's the price you
have to pay so what I'm just gonna make
sure that the phone is up in my mic so
everyone can hear it what do I say you
say hello Matt lin-manuel Miranda this
is Claudia but it's the same the same
buzzer anymore be like it's October
first I've giving you a whole year
where's my $200 okay this isn't how you
run a business
oh man I'm like freaking out like okay
oh my god I don't know I don't know this
is all you by the way because I don't
know if I would do something like this
and we should have pre-recorded it
because you just never know what's gonna
happen the intern kid I'm joking hello
hi this is Claudia Ostra is this mr.
Lynn hi how are you
good I owe you $200
[Music]
tomorrow okay so what's the best way for
me to come get it from you I'll make it
as easy as possible okay great so I will
I will email you a time in place thank
you very much I appreciate it
Wow wait that was so civil and my feet
he remembered I can't explain it like I
don't want it and I certainly don't mean
I really that's the best thing that's
the best it could have gone wait except
he told jag and clip literally I was so
afraid of boys he was gonna say he's
very volatile and gets very angry and
you know there is a chance that it was
these clips have reached him at this
point right and why did he say clips on
I thought he meant clip like the video I
mean she may go we're being short with
him like clip yeah but if you work
because you did you were a little short
with him but anyone who has been Oh 2
inch dollars for a year might be short
actually it's a year and a half
technically a middle I literally was out
of no choice I feel like so scared like
literally like I I don't want it that's
the thing I don't want the money for so
many reasons like one it's just like I
need to keep the joke going like I
really wish he like yeah we need to put
it to bed but to also like I don't
really want to take money from someone
like who just needs it do you know to me
but here's the thing it seems like oh
hey this definitely has been a
transformative year for lin-manuel
Miranda because not only is he
acknowledging he's accepting and like
what that's the first step in a process
is to like acknowledge that you have a
problem he remembered the $200 he's
gonna get it she would sounds like he's
in a way better place than he was a year
ago but I have to meet him for it like
IRL no you guys have to come with me oh
of course
or just be like leave it here and then
we'll pick it up okay but also I think
you'll get into the same cycle your hero
and I can't in good conscience like
deposit it into my bank account I will
donate it to a charity of the toasters
choice okay yes everyone get together
and let me know which one works that is
a lovely sentiment I just like oh my God
look I have the worst thing I never said
you go so well like so civil like -
almost as if we like planned him no like
we
hareton no but like we did it and I
can't leave he answered the phone honest
I can't believe he like still remembers
because he's legit 100 years old I feel
bad if I were to put in this chapter
behind us you know me it's a new era of
the toast yeah and I look forward to
next year on October 1st really going
out for a champagne dinner do you think
with at least $200 do you think he's
gonna give it in cash or cheque cheque
like cashier's check when he picked up
like I've literally like like I'm I I
pooped like extra did yeah I had like
the physical manifestation of a shard
without like actual right because this
is gonna be a three-hour show and if
you're sitting in your own soils
it's not gonna know I can't be soiling
myself while talking about the wonderful
weekend that we had where our sister got
engaged and obviously we knew about it
and on Friday like I really was wanting
to like leave like a hint and be like so
that people could look back and be like
they knew when we're ahead but like not
at the risk of ruining it and like being
dumb and then I thought oh if you look
back you probably see that Claudia asked
me what we're what I'm doing this
weekend and I got a little awkward and I
was like hanging with my family so I
mean - make sense I was also trying to
get Olivia to guest host with me on
Thursday that would have been great
it's like everyone have asked your
questions about her and Zak and cheese
would have been so oblivious and then we
would have talked to her like a week
from now and it would have been just
really cute to have that yeah the day
before she got engaged but of course she
couldn't make the business woman special
isn't really flexible when it comes to
scheduling no I know what it needs to be
flexible when it comes to the toasts but
I am slated to have her as my guest
co-host on Friday so you can ask her all
year and even related questions it was
such a beautiful weekend such a big boy
he's so happy it's oh my god homegirl is
so happy like that's really the best
part about like when someone gets
engaged like I was a nightmare I was
like very happy obviously but like I was
just like a planning nightmare
bridezilla I'm like Olivia it's just
like so like mature engagement week like
that we had the party like oh this is
true you're just on a high and it's just
so nice to see anyone like at their
happiest like yeah this is what they
look like at their happiest no totally
and like I just feel like a lot of the
things that like Olivia usually cares
about like she didn't care about like
homegirl would never wear white ever and
like she just went out and got a white
dress and like just did it cuz like
she's embracing the bridal vibe even
though I literally like will I bet my
life Olivia's gonna wear a black wedding
dress I literally was just gonna say I
wouldn't be surprised if she wore a
black wedding dress and honestly she
should like you should be true to
yourself like I couldn't be more in a
pink wedding
if I found that I loved like I don't
think that that's that crazy well no
like a like a blush one one that's like
almost white yeah like look at your
sweater yeah yeah we're honestly like it
would depend on yuusha no I don't wear a
fuchsia in real life it doesn't go well
with your hair but I personally I'm
wearing white but Olivia should wear
black yeah so it happened on Friday
night like right before we usually do
Shabbat dinner and so it's like this
whole big surprise everyone's families
were there I was so really freaking out
I know honestly we saw her walk into the
building like we were looking down from
the window and from the time that like
she did the proposal to like she got
back to our apartment like was so long
like how long does it take it's like
that question we didn't know what to do
with ourselves we were like okay let's
be quiet and it'll be surprised we were
like waiting by the doors are fine for
10 minutes never like um this is stupid
let's have a hot dog and like then it
was like 20 Morgan and smell we're like
imagine if we were just quiet the whole
time right because they had done the
proposal obviously and then like taking
a bunch of photos and just for like
relishing in the moment but like for us
like you really think about like how
long does a proposal take I don't know I
don't I after my proposal I had a full
blown photo shoot it was like so
beautiful it was sunset Anthony Vasquez
and Co were there of course and it's
really nice to have all those photos now
but like I was crying Zach is wearing
more lipstick than I am okay it's just
like so management shoot me and Anthony
Vasquez to hit up Lincoln Center like
months later when I had like lost a
little bit of weight and I didn't look
like such like a I mean I was wearing a
romper like I just unforgivable
wait so you don't like you don't like
your engagement picture you don't like
how you look from the engagement
oh no okay so I did the like Ben had a
photographer at the engagement cuz I
like I really want to capture the moment
like just for myself right then like her
so she ad on my partnership with the not
calm I was not gonna release the
pictures of me wearing wedges like okay
so then me and Anthony Vasquez and I
warrant literally like the most
uncomfortable shoes and it was the
hottest day of the year and like I was
like peace I can only imagine like what
Anthony Vasquez has to say about me and
he'll tell you later today because being
such a nightmare but like my shoes were
killing me wearing a [ __ ] white dress
and it was so goddamn hot and I just
like I couldn't be bothered with like
any of the [ __ ] so obviously like the
pictures are great but like they're
highly altered and like every time I
think mouseka send me a picture I was
like keep going oh my god
well we will get to all of those
pictures and all of what Anthony Vasquez
thinks of us in our sweaty upper lip
area yeah later in today's show but
overall just like a wonderful begun I
made a big party Saturday and I we're
like we were just it was really just
like anyone
to come say hi Kim came through Taylor
striker and Taylor Donohue were there
and actually the photographer got the
cutest pictures do you see I saw I sent
them to her cuz she like never has like
high quality pictures of them for her
Instagram it's either like Taylor
filming her I saw them and I was like I
was so jealous I was like no it's like
the cutest pictures and they don't know
they're being photographed which is why
they're so cute and the photographer was
just great like I got amazing mix I mean
same I posted nine times since the last
time I sat in this chair yeah and you
know what it's like you're really
concerned with your flow these days and
the party was at night and had like neon
signs and was just like not your flow
cause should flow is very very
brightness here's my question for all
you flow stars out there and like
Instagram models say you take a great
picture like your sister gets [ __ ]
engaged but the background isn't your
aesthetic and you can't make it pay you
can't make a brown booth white yeah do
you just not post a picture I don't
understand you can make it white like
you would be surprised at like probably
the the bloggers who have like real flow
and like their whole Instagram looks
like a mirage like they probably are
sitting in a booth and they change I ask
anyhow menschell like she was like I
don't take pictures it with brown
everybody I was like even if you took
the most gorgeous photo of yourself with
brown like what would you do and she was
like I would change the color and if you
like didn't need the photo immediately
like I could in Photoshop make it pink
for you right but that's also my
struggle it's hard to be like a premium
ass blogger with flow while also being a
real time planner about so a little too
hasty like that cotton candy picture
that I took on my couch oh you sent you
a promotion look like I should have
posted that um after all the evening
photos like it just didn't it wasn't the
vibe but you know I'm learning as I go
yeah nobody's perfect I got to work it
again and again till I get my flow right
snitch I'm having severe dry mouth if
you could give me some seltzer with some
ice and a cap and a straw no we don't
straw us here anymore sorry but actually
Jackie I by Jackie smuggled some straws
in please I'm like you could probably on
the podcast here am I like No thank you
so much Mitch I really the shot isn't
even cuz of like we're trying to disturb
the Turtles it's like fur morning show
you just need a shot because imagine if
we're like right it's not cute no and
then the lipstick comes off like all
over the cap and it's just it's not a
premium experience and I do it for the
viewers you know right and this is
morning toast day national holiday no I
just can't believe like how smoothly
that way and I was really hoping for
some more drama no I'm so I couldn't I I
wouldn't have been able to take it you
know it's like nice after a year like
this will come full circle I just
don't know I really don't want to meet
him tomorrow and you know what I think
every October first from here on out
first of all we have to establish it as
an morning toast holiday however you do
that we'll have to ask Stassi with
national okay oh yeah but it's you
heavier on October first we should
donate two hundred dollars to a charity
and then maybe if we ever get like
picked up by a network we could do like
two hundred thousand dollars not like
the network right exactly right now
let's just live within our means and
speaking of networks and like big big
time networking big tinysine editors um
I went to the Diana Ross concert last
night with Andy Cohen and it was so
premium he went with three of his
friends and I knew he was gonna be there
and I did everything my power to get
seated next to them which I did and so
it was the four of them and they were
truly having who were they with they
were it was non celeb friend it's people
he writes about in this book I think
Gracie Amanda and it was one woman and
two guys I knew that you would probably
know who they were and they were truly
having the best time it was like us at a
Rascal Flatts concert right and I came
in and I wore like full and eco and
Diana Ross outdoor concert glamour it
was a very hard look to nail that I
nailed the look and I had my elevator
pitch ready and I was like when the time
comes I'm gonna I'm gonna do it but you
know what like it would have hurt the
toast if he had heard the mic he's
having the best time drinking dancing
living with his surgery like if someone
came up to me at a concert that I'm
having the best time and like told me
about their Leto podcasts like the next
time I heard about that podcast I'd be
like oh that annoying person oh yeah
that's a podcast everyone liked that so
instead I just contributed to the Diana
Ross vibe yeah and it was so much fun
and he was so cute but what was so funny
so I like I had the seat next to him it
was available and I took it
oh no one yeah I was sitting I was
sitting next I'm first I was sitting on
the other end of his friends but the
seat on the other side of him was also
reserved for me just in case oh wow
so then I took it and I was sitting
there and every time Diana Ross like did
a costume change everyone would like sit
down for a second and the guy is such a
diva the guy next to me keep staring at
me and he was like wow you're so
beautiful like what do you do do you do
anything like with your looks and I'm
like yeah actually I'm a morning show it
was the guy next to you with Andi no oh
just like a random him like a Mook I do
a show it's called the morning toast
he's like where did stream I'm like you
know it's on YouTube it's do with my
sister digital series or whatever it's
like this is conversation you were meant
to be today I think it's the other
having like a
in conversations that is so funny but
many heard you maybe may need it he did
it but it was just so fun it was some
nice like I never I don't think I've
ever eat I know what we've been watching
up inside but just to see him out in the
wild he was really having such a nice
time and I'm so happy for him yeah and
she put on an amazing show
I saw the like half of it in your
interim stories because you will always
be a girl who Instagram stories an
entire concert but I was also
instagramming more so that I could turn
to of course of course and I'd love to
hear like that celebs like are who they
are do you know today means she was
being so well she's like no I wasn't
joking I heard was her man oh sorry well
she's the trustee office at one time she
called the sound guy over from the state
cop got him on stage to like tell him to
do something differently it was so funny
she was like talking to the security
guards like telling them how to do their
job on the 4th wall she was yeah she was
really breaking the fourth wall
much like genican and Kendall's gender
last night I will talk about it which
we'll get into no wait um I was talking
about Andy though like I feel like
they're definitely like toasters and
just people in general who were like I
met Andy he's a dick because like if
you're so famous at any point in the day
for your bad mood like someone's gonna
encounter you and like you're just not
feeling it but I love to hear positive
experiences and I find that with Andy I
hear a lot more positive than negative
and okay so my friend Eric who you know
he's a restaurateur and I keep trying to
like get him to open up an tano's in the
city but he's not into it he owns a
bunch of restaurants like the Wayfarer
which is where we had Olivia's party
this weekend but he's opening a new
restaurant that literally opens today at
1 o'clock with Antony are you going yes
I've been so are they serving grapefruit
and avocado and calling it a salad to a
NASCAR Jagan yes like literally so it's
called the village den it actually like
used to be like a diner in the West
Village it's like an iconic place and it
closed so Seth uh Eric and his partner
like bought it and bought the name and
like they're just revamping it as like
diners are like so passe it's like
Health diner and it's with Antony and
Antony's supposed to be there all week
so I'm gonna go today and Eric said he
might be there and I'm just gonna get a
photo but Andy lives in the neighborhood
and loved the original dent and he's
been there twice already you're trying
to get a photo with Antony yeah do you
like him
well I've he's my least favorite scene
but I like love queer eyes so I just
want a photo I'm one step closer to JB
I'm totally but he's my least favorite
to 100% yeah 100% great and if it he's
just a late he's just everyone's
favorite cuz he's technically like
people he's handsome which is like not
fair I just something people should get
things because like they're good-looking
and be like they're his role is so
unnecessary in the show like they could
do the whole show without him and the
person would end up just as bet just as
good maybe even better off you know
right I'm trying to even think who I
think is the best looking but no I'm
getting really close to enemies but I
was trying to say these okay through the
village and which I'll be having lunch
right today if anyone wants to come so
moral of the story is that I think I
like when he sees me again later in life
which he will he will think of me
favorably I think I made a good
impression yeah it was like that's such
a good point it's not about the battle
it's about the war right so it's like
MIT in this moment we didn't get picked
up but it's like when we cross his desk
next time and who sees our pictures
they'll be like oh they're nice girls
right they don't trigger any negative
memories right it's like last year you
didn't get your $200 but you're gonna
win the war yeah exactly
okay wow what a weekend but yes when we
posted that picture of Jackie with the
caption secret project we were just [ __ ]
starters totally I figured you guys
wouldn't know that about us if you
watched my stories it was clear that I
wasn't I wasn't there working you know
it was um it was just big thirst he fell
into the thirst trap you fell for it
yeah I got called by the thirst trap
okay are you ready yes to be cover all
of our than other bases also I just
wanted to like give a moment it is the
one-year anniversary of fruit 51 do you
say router root I say root depends what
I'm talking about I feel like sir can we
take an alternate route but route 66
yeah route 66 get your kicks on Route 66
it's the one-year anniversary and I just
like there's I feel like route 51 is so
close to the toaster community because
like so many of them were there I think
there was a master post in one of the
toaster script today about girls who
there were two girls who were like I was
there but I had to leave early because I
had something and I didn't wanna see
Jason Aldean like crazy that's so crazy
it's just like the worst day ever
but that's it um okay well now on that
sad note some happier news but without
further ado here are our fast sized
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your more
toast first up some really happy news
for you and your bestie witness Paltrow
shares her first photo after marrying
Brad Falchuk in some very low-key
wedding bands witness Paltrow was
showing off her wedding ring bling on
Sunday the actress took to Instagram
where she shared a photo of her hand
resting over her new husband brow Brad
Falchuk
the creator of the best show of all time
which you think would be Glee but it's
actually scream queens I'm good
putting their slender gold wedding bands
on display Paltrow and foul Chuck tied
the knot on Saturday in the Hamptons and
were toasted by a bevy of their a-list
friends including including Robert
Downey jr. on Friday night Jerry and
Jessica Seinfeld hosted the couple's
rehearsal dinner at their home several
celebs wish the newlyweds well following
Paltrow's post including Glee's Matthew
Marcin a rod elle macpherson etc i
absolutely live breathe and die for
Gwyneth Paltrow and for a while I was
like really like not into her when she
started goop and she was conscious
uncoupling and she was just like not in
tune with like reality right and it's
like you would think that you and
windpower have nothing in common right
but you have everything in common we do
you guys just were fast friends
oh yeah of course of course of course
and it's really like opposites attract
it's so true but I feel like she's like
Shh I feel like people who don't know
her which is like everyone just like
know about her what she puts out in the
world which is like goop and like 100
all her face masks for your vagina like
not good but so when I met her I was
like oh this [ __ ] and she literally is
like an angel like her first all her
face is just perfect symmetrical
symmetrically freckle II like just
perfect everything you wanted to be and
she couldn't been more lovely to me like
someone she didn't know and someone who
was obviously like someone's plus-one
and was like obviously like a thirst
monster she like didn't like care that I
was a thirst months when she was
donation vitamin her house for lunch and
like with her kids and like her kids we
were so cute and so sweet and she's like
obsessed with her kids and like you
would tell her priorities are literally
just like the children right that's like
it's not about being a service monster
it's what you do want to get there yeah
and what I'm doing is just preaching to
the world that Gwyneth Paltrow's truly
misunderstood well it seems like she's
found someone who understands oh and
Brad was there and he's just like such a
supportive husband and so odd I really
shipped these two it makes me like I
like when celebrities like date people
in the industry because obviously they
have to yes it's like you know only they
understand only they understand that
it's
not someone that you compete with on it
like she's not competing with him for
jobs yeah he can give her jobs and she
can give him jobs what kind of job Steve
Jobs what kind of jobs no love her love
them happy for them happy for Brad happy
for Jessica Seinfeld I just feel like
she loves being in the center of
attention
happy for Chris Martin because I feel
like he just wants you know pop around
and hoe it up but I feel like they have
a good like post marriage relationship
yeah consciously uncoupling yes and [ __ ]
but I feel like now that she's really
moved on wholeheartedly like he can go
back around with like Alexa Chung Perry
Johnson Dakota Sean and Finn and like do
whatever he wants
yeah and like no one cares and yeah and
like be like a bad member fair share
yeah yeah of not worth I know yeah
Nicole please legit for sure they
already did the Super Bowl been there
done that
did they yeah they did it with Bruno
Mars and oh yeah Jemima Viva la Vida was
like this song of the world like it
didn't stop playing everywhere I feel
like every time they really used two
songs it's it's like that for good or
for bad remember when they came out with
a song with the chain-smoked I was just
gonna say that sounds great
no but it's like then just like it's
really good yes but exactly they felt
the need that they needed to do that
just like says something you know but at
least they're trying to keep up and go
to the iHeartRadio awards no that's
unforgivable like it just says something
yeah there's certain rewards like you
just win you don't go to there there's
certain words that shouldn't even be on
your radar skin is that you didn't have
a ceremony right knows like if Dean for
the bachelors they're like the Coldplay
bit fans Martin doesn't need to be there
it couldn't be only a word show worth
showing up to is there Aziz yes and
we'll be there and hopefully we'll be
winning this year hopefully we'll be
hosting one day that's really like a
dream no I know that's unrealistic goal
no I know yeah yeah I think so are that
TV maybe it's digital but so we have a
better chance but so like do people get
nominated for like worst movie like do
they show up if they were smart they
would is there an actual ceremony or
they just like give him out um
the Razzies being a thing is like one of
the funniest things no but I just want
to say something because I remember
there was one year Sandra Bullock was
nominated for a Razzie for worst actress
and Steve while also nominated for Best
Actress in the blindside
when Isis to be what's called all about
all about Steve which is just hilarious
in itself but justice for her
because talk about diverse Bradley
Cooper was also in that movie a movie oh
and it's like people only make fun of
her for it when it's like she had like a
weird period where she was like
Katherine Heigl Aang and was in all
these rom-coms like the proposal right
oh that's see it's like if you throw
enough [ __ ] again so while something
will stick and it was a blond fun and it
was and also the proposal as a great
movie I don't remember seeing it because
I was like with a boy in the movie like
in the seventh grade and we made out the
whole time scandal I'm speaking up I
watched it - ass movie of the week and
we do not have time to talk about it
today but we will talk about it tomorrow
that's that's it's it requires an
in-depth conversation yes so that
everyone you have one more day to watch
room it is on Netflix free if you have a
Netflix subscription which you clearly
do so we'll talk about it tomorrow lots
of thoughts
okay ready for the next story yes
Congrats Brad and Gwyn Congrats really
crazy next story Lindsay Lohan
encounters a refugee family in a bizarre
video and it does not end well Lindsay
Lohan posted a bizarre video on
Instagram live on Saturday showing her
filming what appeared to be a possibly
homeless family of four who she thinks
are Syrian refugees in the footage the
32 year old Mean Girls star insists on
helping the woman and two boys for
paying for a hotel room for them the
woman was not having it after the adults
and the children began walking away from
the actress she loudly accuses the man
and woman of child trafficking and
insists on taking the kids with her the
woman then angrily gets into a brief
physical altercation with her Lohan has
not commented further on the video which
may have been filmed in Moscow as she
had shared a photo of herself there
earlier in the footage the actress who
has lived abroad over the past few years
occasionally says words in Russian as
well as Arabic quote hey everyone I just
want to show you a family that I met a
Syrian refugee family she says in the
video quote tell me your story so that I
can help you what do you need do you
want me to give you a hotel so I want to
tell I want you to tell America what you
need and I will get it for you quote
yalla Habibi
which means come on my dear or tell us
one of the book in the words of Luanne
yeah-ha quote you want to come with me
come with me come come I'll take care
let me take care of you guys do you want
to stay in hotel tonight do you want to
watch movies either The Parent Trap Mean
Girls our Freaky Friday yeah it'd be so
cool right to watch a movie on a TV or
computer let's go you're gonna be the
bus from now on I'll take you with me
and we will see them tomorrow okay
basically if you haven't
video I highly encourage you to watch it
but if you here's what happens she goes
live on Instagram for like ten minutes
and in the ten minutes she's like on the
streets in pitch black in the middle of
the night like and there's this family
who they're saying is homeless but
there's no they're on the street like
walking but i don't--there's know at one
point she also says it's they're a
refugee family which there's no proof of
it either like they're just a family and
like she is attacking them like first
she's just like expressing concern that
the kids look like they they like need
her help and then like the parents start
taking them the kids away from like this
crazy lady who's filming them and she
starts following them first of all you
can't film people's kids like you just
can't like that's hard rule of thumb
like we live in a disgusting world where
everyone no one has privacy but like you
can't film other people's kids without
the consent of their parents first of
all second of all like who are like
accusing them of trafficking what didn't
she didn't even say like what she saw
that she thought that they were
trafficking like you're trafficking them
I try to take them into your car and 12
hotel right you're trying to lure
children into a hotel with movies I saw
a movie like that it's called group yeah
so like you're accusing this family of
trafficking their kids when like you
that's literally what you're doing and
then you're like yelling at them telling
them don't [ __ ] with Pakistan I'm like
what and then the mom shoves you and
honestly like I'm with the mom shilling
in a big show I mean when she got shoved
the whole movie she was talking I mean
the whole thing live stream she was
talking like with this weird like accent
and like saying that this family was bad
for Arab culture and then the second she
got shoved which was the best part of
the video that unfortunately you
couldn't see cuz it was dark out her
accent completely disappears right
that's hilarious also the video is 10
minutes so she's badgering this family
for 10 minutes and then the mom finally
shoves her like I don't know if I could
have been that patient right for 10
minutes and it's like she doesn't even
look like Lindsay Lohan anymore so even
if the mom like had been a fan of her
work back in the day she didn't know who
was talking to her so a wee random woman
with her phone in your kid's face I
would give myself one minute flat it was
just the weirdest sequence of events I
feel like every piece of information I
now hear about Lindsay Lohan like these
days it's just so concerning it's
weirder than the next she is so odd with
her accents she's been through like do
you remember when she was just like
Herbie fully loaded like the belle of
the ball the Bella graduated from Disney
but was still like family-friendly
the star that and by the way even when
she went off the rails and was still
acting she's like Georgia Rules era oh
my god she was still an amazing actress
like she really is talented at the craft
and Georgia rule was like such a great
movie wow I haven't thought about that
movie in a while thank you for being it
up we should make that a toast movie of
the way first write it down write it
down because the character in the movie
is like going through this like bad gal
era where like she hates Authority and
like that was really Lindsay at the time
and it's just such an iconic movie wow I
love that really it's so it's like she
really can act
we gotta I don't even know and she's
beyond saving also it's like we thought
the craziest thing she could do would be
like this is how you throw a party and
we can do this [ __ ] right it's like no
this is how you attempt to kidnap
refugee children it's really it's the
weirdest thing like the video is ten
minute song but really like the core of
like the importance it's like 45 seconds
where she's like chasing them down and
yelling things and then gets shoved and
then her actually goes away and then the
livestream ends but she has been like
people have been reaching out to him
like she hasn't said one thing about
this whole entire saga
well that makes me think that maybe she
has some semblance of sentence left
because she could be arrested like she's
trying to steal somebody's kids and you
can't film people's kids for sure
especially not live where it's like
there's no buffer it's going out even if
you film them you might not do anything
with it right there's a difference but
just like they're up it's on demand
their live now it was just so odd do you
follow her no no I did for a while but
um I guess I never like engage with her
post so the new algorithm like never let
me show her [ __ ] and then I'm like what
am i following I've never seen her posts
right oh so like I don't want to follow
stuff like like crazy people on
Instagram like I want to follow premium
content with flow
yeah premium content content only yeah
word syllabi okay now we're getting into
our business segment because really not
that much sub news happening at a star
can you see it no guess what you I oh my
god you have a sty I'm gonna go that one
no it's this one okay it's like day one
it hurts so bad like even to blink do
you know any mean and like every time I
get to ties all the time probably cuz
I'm like a dirty and don't watch my face
but I've been washing my face like so
like I've been so good about my face for
like the last month and I just feel like
no good deed man Wow Isak really creepy
i stuff creeps me out no I know and like
when I blink it hurts so bad and I gotta
get like warm tea bags and put it on my
eye and like teabag myself oh my god I'm
good luck I'm thinking of you truly
okay next up facebook hack what to do if
you're affected this is wild you guys if
you were wondering last week while you
were just logged out of your facebook on
although you probably weren't Isis you
probably weren't aware on Facebook I was
aware on Instagram because I kept
getting notifications to log back in to
my Instagram through Facebook Oh mine I
don't even know when it's connected
anymore but I got logged out of my
facebook on my iPad and my phone I
thought that was just weird too and then
it turns out there was a major hacking
and I guess if you were logged out you
were probably affected but Sheryl
Sandberg no but they logged everyone out
oh really as a security precaution
I heard fifty million users were
affected and they logged out 90 million
so maybe we were part of the lucky 40
Sheryl Sandberg Mark Zuckerberg and me
and there's a good chance you - welcome
to the not so exclusive club Facebook
users who may have been affected by a
major security breach hackers may have
gained access to nearly 50 million
accounts by exploiting flaws in the
social networks code Facebook said
Friday
it's the largest breach in the company's
history Facebook said it has notified
Lauren law enforcement officials and
patch the code vulnerability that
hackers exploited a lot of questions
remain we don't know for sure whether
the impacted accounts were misused it's
also unclear exactly what information
hackers may have access though facebook
said passwords and payment information
were not compromised what do you need to
pay for on Facebook if I have a credit
card on Facebook it's truly from 2006
when I used to buy birthday gifts for my
friends on Facebook now if I had credit
card is like buying lives on farmville
right you can have that kind of card in
for me is two bucks so hard
good farmville so I mean you don't do
venmo through pay Facebook really
shouldn't have your credit unless you do
like Facebook through Spotify and then
like they really got in there when I was
oh when I was in high school there was a
girl that I was friends with who I'd
like a boyfriend who was like older and
hotter and like we all just didn't they
like would like like do stuff and like
we were all like 14 and we were like
tell us to that like your older
boyfriend and like they had such a
mature relationship when we were all
like we had no boobs and we were like
weenies we just like live by carelessly
through her and for like uh their
anniversary she like went out and got
him like golf shoes like engraved like
really special they had like a serious
relationship and he gave her a $5
Starbucks gift card on Facebook like we
were freaking out it was oh and she was
dating yeah
yet until like we like we're obsessed
with them and then like he totally let
her down you know so his credit card is
still probably Facebook I'm probably was
now finally karma sometimes she's slow
you know yeah she works below the
surface everything really truly happens
for a reason
so far our initial investigation has not
shown that these Tobin's were used to
access any private messages our post
supportive posts anything to these
accounts Mark Zuckerberg told reporters
Friday but this of course may change as
we learn more okay
like I mean the morning shows our
Facebook group is single-handedly
keeping Facebook afloat as a company so
I just want to say that because if it
weren't for Facebook
I'd the toasters Facebook group like I
would have no use for Facebook I
wouldn't be surprised if this was like
TMZ hacking Facebook just to get some
like salacious tidbits from our group
okay so like it's like you just answer
your questions and join know we'll let
you know yeah we get trolls from reddit
like your vibe here's the thing about
Facebook hacks like first of all it's a
biggest company in the world they
literally make like 60 billion dollars a
year like get some security like get
some security guards some bodyguards I
don't know what it takes but like it
can't be that hard you know
second of all like who the [ __ ] is
trying to get information from Facebook
like if someone literally gave me the
key to all the data at Facebook that I
key like here no one's gonna find out it
to you like here's all the information
you need I'd be like cool and like give
it to someone else like I couldn't care
less
so what are they trying to jail first of
all and who the [ __ ] is that a big
enough loser like spend their time like
hacking Facebook like hack something
cool like whitehouse.gov or something
you know or venmo something useful chase
like go see how much like all your
friends have in their bank account you
know yeah I guess if I hacked Facebook
and it was tied to Instagram I would
make everyone in the hack follow me so
I'd have 50 million followers now oh of
course I mean I can totally see the
value when packing Instagram yeah no
doubt maybe they went through Facebook
cuz it's like no one's really looking
there anymore I used to like Mark
Zuckerberg always finds himself you know
in trouble with the law in precarious
situations he had to do like remembered
all those when he went to the Senate
what was it like a deposition yeah
because of something like this I know
it's like we're giving out like
information to Russia yeah but I think
Macke say were like giving it out shada
Lee this in this case it was taken from
but maybe they're trying to make it seem
like it was taken from em they literally
can't get their security together like
it it's like it's it's not like you know
like this is some startup you know
having like fiscal issues like this
isn't like the biggest company in the
world they're public like figured out
hire a bodyguard get like
security you know right antivirus yeah I
don't know
just a thought yeah um next up in a
developing story from last week that has
reached a close Elon Musk settles with
the SEC and agrees to step down as the
Tesla chairman Elon Musk's Tesla chief
executive have reached a deal with the
Securities and Exchange Commission to
settle a series of security fraud
charges brought against him on Thursday
the agency announced on Sunday under the
terms of the settlement musk has agreed
to step down as chairman of the silicon
valley-based company but will remain in
his post to CEO so that seems like not a
big deal you know they want you to think
he's making these big steps but really
it's like day-to-day doesn't really
change Tesla and you know it's like
Charles went from being the head no so
oh you didn't learn anything you didn't
I'm not quite everything
sorry Tesla and was so glad I was like
actually listening sometimes I like read
the comments and like I would have
actually okay Tesla and must we'll each
pay a separate sign of 20 million
dollars the SEC said in a press release
so Elon Musk will take a [ __ ] and hand
it over to the SEC how much was a 220 20
million that's a lot from Tesla Oh from
Elon both each pay separate that's a
time I don't know a couple of Tesla's on
the market yes sure his net worth is 19
point 7 billion so he's fine so we
watched
yeah I just looked it up it's nothing
for him oh my god think of what we could
do with 19 deal and that like just gets
him off the hook you know what's so
crazy that was like when you hear about
like the world's richest people like you
don't think he thought must you think
like Jeff Bezos Bill Gates like 19
billion dollars doesn't even make you
the richest person or like top 20 this
is 164 oh my god imagine what I could do
with I mean first of all every single
toaster who's been like loyal gets a
million dollars done done so that's like
2 million up no kidding no it's it's
like three thousand times a million
three hundred great great I'm fine
happily and then oh my god cuz if you
think about it like must I get to a
billion I saw 163 more Wow I would
[ __ ] live for a hundred and sixty
four billion dollars honestly I would
give myself liposuction and then like a
reshoot my wedding pictures with Anthony
Vasquez because I you ever knew your
vows but then that's also like a curse
no I'm not - I'm just me shooting the
pictures okay and maybe like I'll take a
private jet they're good to have but
then I'll like get on a private jet and
go to like a Fiji and like do it there
- ooh but it's hot there I don't get a
sleeveless dress because I'm so skinny
now go to Iceland whatever Reykjavik
after the fine he'll be ineligible to be
reelected chairman for three years well
anyways chairman of the board is like
it's a perfect position so I feel like
he'll actually be glad to be relieved of
those duties maybe he did all of this
for that for that so he can just go back
to being the CEO of the company making
the business decisions and getting us on
the moon no I really feel like this was
the best decision for for everyone I
think that being in the spotlight when
it comes to Tesla and like its finances
was too much it proved to be too much
for him and he he couldn't handle it so
I'm really like excited for him to kind
of take a step back and really focus I'm
like the engineering of it all and not
really like the PR business like front
facing side of it and he needs to go
back to being like a private businessman
not a public one like he's not Evan
Spiegel and he's like can't just be
married to a model and living the high
life like if you're really gonna
innovate which Evans no longer doing but
you can't innovate and be a celebrity
like no no no you go over here why don't
you date like someone in the in the tech
smart industry to private people just
something change the world it's not that
hard are you done with this story I
could tell you something about
acceptance I have to share something
weird
so I've been hearing I follow these
girls on Instagram called the home at it
and basically they're just like
organizational like freaks and they like
go into people's houses and like take
over their closets and they're like so
premium and they'd like the best photos
and they really organize people's like
closets make up bathroom looks so cute I
love it
so they got a show on Reese
Witherspoon's like fake TV network that
like doesn't really exist on like the TV
just like it's like the toaster yeah and
she's been like producing content for
him I've heard a lot about it and I
heard that these girls had a show but I
don't know how to watch it but then
someone one of the choices gave me their
DirecTV now login so I can watch a
toaster concert and I was just like
[ __ ] around on the app and it had the
home edit so I watched it I only watched
episode that had celebrities in it so
they did like six episodes and two of
them were celebrities Shay Mitchell did
her YouTube space like in her house she
like has like a guest house that she
made her office YouTube glam room and
then Olivia culpo
who did her bathroom where like all of
her makeup stockroom is and they did the
weirdest thing on the show they like
introduce the people as like you know
and it says like it would say Jackie Oh
morning shows or like influencer they
just kept saying the weirdest things
about like Olivia culpo activist and
model they know just model
often posts like activists like things
on Instagram but like not really yeah
what Shay Mitchell entrepreneur and
actress it was so weird like first they
did with Olivia cope I'm like oh that's
fierce that was probably like a
contingency she's like I'll go on your
fake show but you just have told me an
activist and then like with shame each I
was like what the hell are they doing
that's so funny because those are
actually two people who have so many
jobs except for those things because
well maybe a couple should have an
influencer model no but Olivia culpo is
on model squad she's influence or model
restaurateur um what uh designer yeah
like I mean she's an actress and an
influencer she has three million YouTube
subscribers like I just thought it was
so weird that they were using these
adjectives to describe them that like
we're not correct that's so weird so
what would yours be slob I don't know no
it would be evil if you could chew comic
comic and just one word I feel like when
you have to say to you it's like you
have to prove something you're not yeah
like you're not established as one so
you have to do both yeah so I just
thought that was so weird but the show
was so good they made you Shea's room
glam room like so cute they organized it
so well and they don't [ __ ] it's
like she has so many chords and by the
way she called it charger heaven it's
not weird that's when we were younger we
know we have like a random like parts in
our closet where we would like shove all
these chargers cuz like we had digital
cameras laptops like you didn't know
like what to keep and what not to keep
so you just gave everything and then
when you needed something you would go
to be called a charger heaven and just
like pick up something and hope that it
worked so she had all these courts
because she has so much equipment she
was like this is charge or heaven I was
like wow so what did they do with all
her course so they separated them and
then put them into bins and then inside
the bins they called it um [ __ ] it was
like they had bins and the bins had
bends okay it was really smart but the
girl was literally like looking up on
you on the internet like what all the
cords doing their work these are camera
cords like she was doing like we're
gonna sing by what type of device and it
was just like so smart and well thought
out like when you think they wouldn't
like they just throw some [ __ ] like for
the show like they were doing it's so
legit and I was like oh my god I need
these girls so it comes back so you
liked the show um yeah yeah it was good
I liked it I just like when people come
an internet like transcend to
traditional media and like don't
embarrass themselves Olivares ah right
like and then they make it so much
harder like my grace Helbig got her
chair I'm like it wasn't good like she
makes it harder for anyone else
for sure but we have two more fighting
chances coming so I left so I was just
gonna say like I really like want the
lady gang to succeed because then it'll
just be like oh people with popular
podcasts can we have TV shows great and
just women supporting other women and
then what see otherwise eful ups but
she's a real celeb and her shoots in
industry so she's getting this show
because of her Instagram stories yeah
honestly I think the lady game will do
better than busy tonight okay and they
could have done a better name with to
her name being busy I just want to say
tell your friends I'm busy tonight like
that was the only time I like understood
it until I thought the same exact kept
saying the name and then she and then
the end tag line but the commercials
like tell your friends you're busy oh my
god that's cute like that's what I
understood it but I think they could
have done more with her name being busy
understood okay the fifth and final
story is something that I read this
weekend this just really shook me to the
core and I found it to be so interesting
and I wanted to share it with the
toasters it's very Daily Mail soundtrap
story vibe yes identity of perfectly
preserved black woman found in New York
City buried in an iron coffin wearing
knee-high socks is revealed to be 26
year-old who died from smallpox in 1851
and was laid to rest in the church
founded by the first generation of free
african-americans
this story is so crazy construction
workers in 2011
discovered the human remains buried
under an abandoned lot in the Elmhurst
neighborhood of Queens New York does
imagine like being a guy in Queens who
works in construction like going to work
just to you know like punch the clock
and like you end up finding a body it's
so SVU it's so SEO but it's like if you
read them a Daily Mail it seems to
happen like often right where the body
was in such good condition that they
called 9-1-1 fearing a homicide what yes
but forensic experts discovered she was
actually born before the Civil War and
died in 1851 she was identified as
Martha Peterson daughter of John and
Jane Peterson prominent figures in new
towns newly created free black community
Martha the woman works for coffin-maker
Fisk and Raymond the same company that
made Martha's iron coffin which kept her
preserved for a hundred and fifty years
Pookie she died at age 26 from smallpox
and her lesions were still visible
that's how well she was preserved okay
first of all this couldn't be a greater
commercial for the casket company what
was it called Fisk and Raymond I doubt
they're still in business Billy with cut
with coffins like that and then wait
just like when they found the body like
you would like her face wasn't there
oh my god they have a picture oh my god
we can't show it no we can but you can I
don't know
wow that is [ __ ] why are on the daily
man I'll search Martha Raymond wait this
is so sad why is it sad no I mean that
she like died at 26
oh yes it happened 200 years ago but it
happened so long ago and she came from
sister like an established family right
and now we know so much about this
family I know it's almost like her this
weird like situation is now shedding a
light on the important work of her
family and also I'm the important work
of like census information which brings
me back to 23 me and now I do want to
submit my DNA weight but also that's so
true like the fact that we can identify
like yes those are very well kept
remains but like it's still like I don't
see a face I wouldn't be like oh that's
my friend Martha you know right no but
also everyone who ever knew her and knew
her parents parents parents parents is
dead right but according to the 1850
census of New York City the first to
list everyone by population in the
population by name age sex and race
Martha worked and lived in the household
of white coffin maker william raymond
who had abolitionists leanings but so
the first census came out in 1850
she died happy to be alive during the
census yes like otherwise we would have
no clue who she was I feel like the
census is always getting like a bad rap
by people but like the more that I think
about like there's how I keep track of
everyone right and like now I'm gonna
fill out that form to vigorous I filled
out a census form once and I lied cuz
that was just like [ __ ] the man and I
don't even know why I just feel like I'm
like predisposed to hating the census
but it's like a good program I think I
think so I'm just trying to like see a
lot of us ya know us I think it's fine
right yeah did you feel like everyone is
like this thing against the census or
like maybe it just made I don't know
because you just have it like government
and you just are so scared of them like
what are they gonna do with your
information but now like they're gonna
track you down in Queens no they said
that no critic allegiance up from her
smallpox were preserved like so well
that they actually thought that the
smallpox might still be like a lot oh my
god imagine and now the pox came back
because it was found because of this
coffin how crazy
wait that is such a crazy story and like
you know why Wow Wow
and it just I'm really watching
Desperate Housewives so it's all coming
back to me even though I don't remember
[ __ ] anything the best part and but
Paul like just like took that chest out
of his pool and it's like maybe Martha
was in there
even I don't even remember what just in
the pool yeah that show is so good you
don't remember what's in the chest I
don't remember and I didn't like I know
when I snapped the show opened with Bree
van de Kamp who is far and just the best
character I only am interested in her
segments I thought she was married to
Orson at the time no she listens not Van
Dyck and just wait I don't remember
anything so don't say anything but like
she's with Rex and I just don't remember
but when they're going to couples
counseling and she is so manipulative
that she convinces this therapist that
Freud was actually like a deeply
ungrateful son oh my god it's so funny
and like her sheet is so good and I take
back everything I said about Lynette her
segments are [ __ ] horrible into press
a and I just like I don't like it and
they only get worse and it's like
stressful yeah I guess she really is
like the relatable the relatable one
like not that many women out there are
breeze though we all strive to be but
doesn't it make you want to do the
dishes no it just makes me want to like
be on top of my [ __ ] all the time and
doesn't it make you want to move to
Wisteria Lane oh my god Dream House and
I just like I'm not here for Edie and
it's so funny because watching the show
as like a 12 year old who probably
didn't understand half the stuff that
was going on I really loved teri hatcher
like I identified she was my favorite
character and then the more that I think
about it the more [ __ ] annoying she's
in her eyes too much on her daughter's
the carry exactly like she's so
codependent on her daughter who's just
like trying to grow up to have a normal
life and like none of the finances of
any other women make sense right but I'm
glad because I'm glad that for the most
part financial struggles aren't like a
main storyline because that's just it's
too real it's too right but so in the
theme song they're holding apples that
is taken from what-what because then all
the housewives in every city they hold
oranges diamonds apples peaches all that
stuff no they get like the housewives
got it from Desperate house yeah and
just her eyes made that up why are we
holding apples under a tree like Adam
and Eve yes I believe so
the whole oh because it's a poison apple
I believe and it's like they're like
these women right right right
you know no it's just so interesting
there's so much undertone there mark
cherry is like never forget genius
Desperate Housewives came before of the
Real Housewives and Desperate Housewives
brought us Real Housewives we wouldn't
have had anything real to Bob Holly on
the gate before they they were making a
show about rich women in Orange County
was called beyond the games and it was
inspired by Desperate Housewives much
like Laguna Beach was inspired by The OC
the real Orange County is what they
called it the real Orange County no it's
just like everyone steals that's what
I'm learning
no but and I'm so grateful yeah you know
because imagine like imagine world with
what real house has become like just
from one scripted TV show is insane it's
a whole like they get real tease no but
it's just it's so like that's just an
interesting tidbit that I knew when I
first heard about the Real Housewives
coming up like I saw commercials for it
but now like that I'm so invested in
like a full-time member of the
Housewives franchise I forget that like
its origins are so interesting right to
show you like the Desperate Housewives
like no they're not murdering people but
this is what they have going yeah homes
are going into foreclosure so let's
recap the Kardashians and then we will
bring out our guest for today
Anthony baskets and I'm fishing yes um
what are we doing this week like what's
our schedule okay I'm so glad you asked
tomorrow it is me and you again and hope
because we now everything will be have
settled down like we can just chill out
your toaster see our toasters movies
movie of the week make sure you watch
room tonight hopefully while it's still
daylight don't get too scared do not
what I can't watch just about sizing
that even though room is less scary than
I thought it was gonna be it's not like
suspenseful you know it's just a pit
spell then on Wednesday I you are here
again
Kevin Astrid will be joining us so
exciting I got exciting but like Ashwood
should be nervous cuz I'm coming for her
man right I got a military duty for this
so like they better be worthwhile I had
to pay $200 again
to move my flight to Buffalo I moved it
back like two hours also I'm in Buffalo
two shows one of them sold out one of
them is on so if you want to come by all
means do it and then mean snitch were
headed to Albany and there are tickets
left there as well and then we're going
to Huntsville Alabama which I've been
looking forward to it for a long time
and I've heard there's only 33 tickets
left and that was last night so but the
Huntsville show what day [ __ ] Saturday
so basically like my whole weekend gets
eaten up I work 12 I'm not here this
week anyway so that's fine I'm going to
Dallas with Anthony back oh right you're
doing your my big photo shoot man yeah
my again inspired photo shoot yes okay
Kardashian then on Thursday okay we'll
be joined by Heather McMann to co-host
finally just you know and associate the
palates of the toasters just like ask
ask away she's friends with busy so I'll
find out more about
yeah she's like a better busy I feel
like a lookalike that's the point is she
gonna be on the show
busy tonight I know Bizzy should put her
on the show and then Friday I believe it
Livia will be co-hosting with me um just
have to make sure her businesswoman
schedule allows it and if anyone else is
in New York that like I just have to
have my guess yes so also I forgot to
tell you
Lauren Burnham is gonna be here but when
you're away okay do it without me yeah
tell her I love her then I also need a
co-host who's like in tune you know
counselor snatch oh yeah Michael meeting
you and I've never co-hosted together
let's do it I don't I'll figure it I'll
do it on my face for that I'm my name
okay Monday Tuesday and Tuesday show we
can master Monday Margaret you know what
we'll figure it out yeah offline okay
Kardashians so I feel like every episode
is really structured the same where they
have like the big storyline no [ __ ] no
[ __ ]
and I like the bull [ __ ] babe um but
last one last night's was weird like
there was no real storyline like there
was no drama I didn't get was watch
Kourtney and Kim stuff but then they
like never talked about it and they
never told us what she said in the email
and when they opened the show core Kim
is still in the braid she's wearing when
she introduced everyone to st. two
episodes ago and it's like I understand
that you guys think we're morons I'm
hurt but sure I get it yeah um but like
why the lack of continuity like why
can't you show us things as they happen
what's the big secret right what are we
missing I don't know it's very odd the
way that they like cut and paste
everything like scenes of them like
having lunch and talking about nothing
like literally could be from two years
ago right and so and so why can't you
just serve it up to us as it's happening
and make your job easier and I thought
it was really interesting and I feel
like Kim and Kanye are like opening up
to the show a lot more where they use to
be like super closed off and like for a
moment they were like kind of relatable
just saying how like they have so many
kids in like they don't really like
focus on each other anymore but then
like what they were fighting about like
I couldn't even relate to cuz like get
your own [ __ ] band-aid and stop
complaining about it and just like I
don't even know but like I for a second
I was like oh they're just like us yeah
but then it also like made me sad
because that I feel like that meant that
they were really like scraping the
bottom of the barrel for storylines
because I Kanye would never have agreed
to that when things were good right Oh
what I mean when things were good with
the show like I feel like she really had
to be like babe can I air our dirty
laundry like we're right thirsting yeah
but we're thirsting for content we put
Jen Atkin on a green screen okay so I've
thought last night of an idea that I
think the Kardashians should really make
Oh 30 minutes there is not nearly enough
that goes on every episode and like
there's so much [ __ ] and commercials
and like fake dumb Jen Atkins storylines
that like if they made it 30 minutes
like we'd all be better off but they
don't want to give back here he takes
out of that ad money they would be
making they would be making 50 million
for a contract instead of 100 million
and then same with E like it makes no
sense for anyone except for us but I
watched live which I never do because
usually get to fast-forward through the
commercials but like [ __ ] I really
realized how long the show it is and how
literally thirty percent of it is actual
content right and how much they're
showing you up next previously right
there's so much of that except you know
it those are you in the teaser for
what's to come the rest of the season
like it does look really just courts
because there's like three or four
things that happened like in real life
that they have to address but they
address those three or four things over
22 episodes like please if you do it in
five like that's what some annoying but
so Courtney okay they never said what
Kim said in the email but the gist was
like Scott let's have another baby with
Courtney like not sex obviously but like
let's convince her to do it not me like
she was making it seem Courtney like Kim
wrote this vicious email saying that
Courtney's an evil person like all she
was saying and she said it's the only
family like all she was saying was like
if Courtney asked you about it like
let's persuade her which is like
something we would do totally and it's
like that's I've been thinking this for
so long there's no way this is the first
time it's arisen in the family that
Kourtney and Scott should have another
kid together
of course not it would be amazing but
like the way she was talking about this
email like it was literally written like
in blood it's like so dramatic she's
like looking for a reason just to hate
Kim totally also like it's it's a the
show itself like doesn't give us
anything but it's like these moments
that give us everything and when Kim was
talking to Simon and she was like butter
my water
North was a wild animal at lunch it
seems like noise like eats a lot know
what Simon was like butter on the bread
butter in the water hand in the water
water and drunk last week with the candy
North is eating all the candy
it's so cute like that is such a funny
anecdote about North no totally and I
couldn't bet she was literally being the
bee since she was eating is so funny
it's just like truly so really the world
and it's like I feel like [ __ ] like that
it's like I love seeing like tidbits of
like things that like are just so human
about them but I think they think that's
not interesting and like want to serve
up more fake drama when I was like
really bad and watch them like be
parents and just like be normal then
like making this fake stupid like Paris
drama no toad
oh sorry I'm in Paris that's real drama
I met like Joanna I'm here sitting on my
couch expecting to be interested in
genican scared to get on a horse in
Paris like in a beautiful castle yeah I
don't care so like I don't know what
Kendall steal but the show is because it
was obviously like she was paid to do
this episode but she's not on everyone
and she I do believe that she does have
that anxiety like with the flying stuff
like when she face I'm Kris Jenner that
was sad and like Margo texted me because
I'm Margo was like you are Kendall and
I'm like yeah like she has to go on
trips like with her family or like
members of her like team whereas like I
couldn't do my shows like I was crying
everything in the hotel room and then
Margo came in like now I'm fine for sure
but even when you were crying every
night in the hotel room like that wasn't
your whole story you know also I wasn't
at the ritz-carlton you know being paid
literally millions of dollars right a
bit and also you think about it there
was that mean that was circulating this
weekend how Kendall is worth the least
of all the Kardashian girls at 18
million chopper the hardest but she
works the hardest but that also explains
why she feels the need to like do the
show and make stuff happen yeah but like
literally the one episode that she's
been on this whole season it was so
boring but who was that girl that was
with them she was the most gorgeous girl
I've ever seen they say Mary Phillips
the makeup girl yeah oh my god she is
Steinem wait Margo
your friend emailed her to do with her
makeup right like she got a quote I
don't know maybe it was yeah if someone
of Margo's friends like tried to reach
out and get like it was a special
occasion so she was gonna splurge on it
to get Mary Phillips to do her makeup
cuz she does like Gigi she does everyone
who's twenty thousand dollars yeah oh my
god I didn't realize she was a makeup
artist and I thought she was just a
friend of Kendall's who like wasn't
thirsty enough to get her name on the
tail but she looked like Kristina Kelly
and she was so gorgeous and I couldn't
stop staring at her that was like a
bright spot a spot in that horrible
episode but like oh another bright spot
was genic and explaining how like when
they're in all these beautiful scenarios
and she tries to get like Instagram
content for Kendall yeah thank you
that's what I want to see that and like
Kendall doesn't even like care to do it
no but so they showed two instances in
two different countries where Kendall
was doing
green wait hold on you mean around the
world in four days around the world in
40s around the world in 40s they went to
trapeze yeah that the like having
performed to me before like it can be
super awkward and like people like just
depend on you to talks like you really
have to be like over-the-top because you
don't want ever anyone to like feel
uncomfortable and Kendall just it's like
it's not like that
so every time they show under me it
reads
so awkward like for the person you know
I actually felt like she didn't know K
job I was thinking like wow you really
it's so hard like when you meet people
and you just like have expectations and
I felt like or maybe they just showed us
a few comfortable conversations but I
actually thought wow considering she
seems to be like so like anxious and
socially like awkward sometimes she did
a pretty good job I thought she did a
bad job but I thought it was really
awkward that's hilarious
I'm just so uninteresting like that
whole thing like with the horses and
everything and it's like pouring rain
and she's having them go horseback
riding yeah that castle was really
pretty and it was like such a cute fun
day right and they played that like
Beauty and the Beast type music that was
supposed to feel bad for her like
working but like you live like in Paris
like in Versailles right I'm like let's
talk about what kind of paycheck you
picked up from adidas right that week
for two main grades around the world in
Brittany yeah and then the stuff back
home like so did Scott say he want to
have another kid because then he said he
didn't he seems down for what I like I
feel like if Kourtney's down he's down
yeah I don't know I need more Kris
Jenner like I find that the subplots
that are boring but when Kris Jenner is
involved like I don't find them as
boring aren't Vandelay right and she's
just so funny and she's like he's a good
sport about like people picking on her
like she's a great addition to the show
I totally agree we need less Kourtney
like I need so much less Kourtney and
even Scott like I don't care about them
when Scott was doing yoga with Kourtney
and Khloe and Kim like that was funny
but like I don't need Scott as he
pertains to being the father of the kids
you know any no I don't need Scott
Hennessee pertains to Kourtney I need
him as he pertains to being the father
of the kids otherwise he has no business
right being around like these friends
with Kim and Khloe right like that's
what I like but it's just like the last
night's episode was really not good
there was nothing and they teased so
much on Instagram with like this trailer
of Tristan and all the stuff nothing
happened right
I thought I watched the wrong episode no
because I had something else recording
it was just a first look of two minutes
so stupid and it's they go to Japan soon
and Kourtney and Kim fight but it's
funny when I saw those pictures on
Instagram I was like oh so cute like
they're having like the best sisters
trip I can get they get along so well
lol but when Kourtney got upset about
the baby thing like a lot of it I think
goes back to Eunice who is no longer in
the picture but what we've learned since
via that security camera footage and his
comments on Instagram was like he's very
controlling so like I'm sure she was
thinking like Kim is talking about me
having a baby with another man and
Eunice is gonna say it and yell at me so
hopefully by next season like she's out
from under his thumb and like we'll be a
little more tolerable
well she is dating someone
now who is just like like say what you
want about Yunus but like homeboy was
hot like as hell like for like no one
could argue with that
you know this guy's a little bit more
interesting looking and I wouldn't say
conventionally like Gorge attractive
yeah very fair I honestly when I see
your pictures with like touch with
Justin Bieber or people like thought she
totally then also like Kendall was
eating Justin Bieber yeah but like oh my
god when they were in the car saying
like who Kendall was gonna marry they're
like what's your type and I'm just like
literally nobody and that's what she
said she was like everybody but know so
nobody yeah weird who is she gonna marry
I don't know how old is she she's like a
younger than me I think
and it's like she's like like how old is
she 20 to 13 22 like she's the most
beautiful girl in the world like
traveling the world like who is she
texting you know totally I feel like she
definitely like techsan it off with
Harry Styles I don't think so I don't
know who she's texting but she's texting
someone like can we find it can we get a
name right like hackers get off of
Facebook and tell me who kendall Jenner
is hacking I mean it's Xing I don't want
to see the text I just want to know
who's she's done you know I don't need
specifics I just need names and phone
numbers okay so now that we've literally
shocked our heads off for 60 minutes
straight and got off everything together
I feel really clean okay yeah until
tomorrow us.thank guy and finally we are
going to take a brief pause and we're
gonna bring out today's guest who was
Anthony Vasquez he was he is your
wedding engagement photographer Jackie
stole him for me because he was my first
but I stole him from Robert okay so you
know what all's fair in love and
weddings
we are gonna hound him with questions
about celebrity wedding Steve done he's
done ask him like who some of the most
annoying people he's worked with are
commonly yes no I know it is I'll tell
you afterwards and and we're also gonna
share exclusive pictures from Jackie's
engagement and for my wedding because I
literally like after my wedding never
saw Anthony again and I really need to
make an appointment and pick up motion
pictures for my book was like Ben's
parents are yelling at me and I will do
it but so this is a great way to start
so if you have questions for Anthony
photography wise wedding wise Robert
Herjavec wise shark tank wise feel free
to drop it on the YouTube stream and we
will get it to him ASAP so we will be
right back stay tuned
you
okay thank you for waiting we are back
with Anthony Vasquez photographer to the
stars right these two stars good morning
show stars hi hello oh my gosh okay so
how did we meet we met through friends
Ryan Josh say names yeah yeah yeah so um
and then I walked in and I saw Robert
Herjavec hanging in your office and I
was like sigh where's the paperwork let
me sign let's make a deal Oh
which question about him Jackie's
obsessed with him like and I have the
same wedding planner as him now and I'll
comes photos beautiful it's like he
doesn't even know how much he's meant to
our wedding process yeah how okay so
when you work and he was like thirsty
luck with the People magazine so like
everyone knows that you were the
photographer but are there people that
you work with who are famous who like
don't want any like they're very under
the radar or NDA mm-hmm yeah obviously
you're not correct okay that works
it's too bad too bad about that so plead
interims Robert we did not know well we
kind of did yeah it was very obvious
like the way were so public with people
and you were there it was in where LA
yeah Four Seasons Beverly Hills rich
making that Shark Tank money huh nice
okay so you shoot weddings legit like
four times a week right wanted to wonder
two minds matter very consistent and
what have you seen like budget wise is
the most meta money on who's ever spent
on the wedding that we've done yeah
and was it Roberts hmm I have to say no
not the most expensive wedding we've
ever done okay if I had a gas probably
around like five million wow that is a
home for two that's a quarter of what
Elon Musk had to pay them in New York
that's like literally the subway like
it's your MetroCard really literally but
for other people that's nice but I'm
happy for that hahaha
and so when someone do you find actually
that most of it like your business comes
from Instagram I feel like the Bridal
world is like so Instagram yeah I mean
it's crazy so I think now like 90
percent but it'll be weird because it'll
be like I'm friends with Claudia we grew
up together I haven't spoken to her at
night
19 years Jackie I went to kindergarten
with her but I saw your picture sorry
ma'am but they feel like yeah
there's friends but they're not friends
yeah it still comes from Instagram yeah
but they know you
Instagram changed the way that you like
shoot weddings because first of all
people do Brides like want to post
immediately so how do you get that to
them and like do people now want like
insta friendly photos whereas before it
was like not a factor yes it's like
totally trend change the way
photographers shoot the content that
brides want style the weddings I mean
now it's like you have to shoot vertical
versus horizontal because vertical
pictures getting more pickup engagement
on Instagram Horizonte image you find
something more vertical gray even though
even though horizontal it's like you get
more not seen theoretically yeah a
street shot but now you on that vertical
shot to gets more engagement on
Instagram yes it's so interesting so
like I was freaking out cuz like for
someone who's like not good with
technology I just kept thinking like of
all the possibilities I like all the
photos from my wedding could be like
accidentally deleted do you know what he
needs it and I think I even asked that
in the meeting I'm like what if you like
lose the memory card I don't know like
just so many things could go wrong and I
love to ask people like what their
biggest like flop is like it was there
ever something that happened where like
the camera like fell into the lake or
something I don't know like where you
lost all the photos I don't know lake or
like falling images like no I mean like
now it's it's really like you have two
memory cards in the camera certain kind
of late almost oh there's a backup
members backup memory bar okay and then
we back up on the day so we have an
editor who get real rare we have a lot
done off of us so there's no way like
external hard drive it's turn oh my god
yeah so you're kind of like conferred so
then what's the quickest you can get the
bride a photo for her to post cuz like
she'll want to post her own photo first
Claudia's was like oh my god I was being
so nuts but like also we were on
deadline remember yeah so I mean I was
like 8 o'clock we needed so we had
better in the past standard wedding like
just a couple pictures before you
obviously edit all them like when's this
early someone he had their wedding day
we like to say like week off okay that's
fair I mean like brides want it the next
day
yeah of course like I try to like you
know precipitate that by saying you know
I do want to like wake up Monday morning
and like not work right so you know if
your weddings like Sunday like it was
couple days yeah that's there but that
being said like everyone wants
everything immediately but you so you do
weddings but you also do like a lot of
content on Instagram that I see like
some vloggers and I'm just curious like
not that you're really gonna spell to
you but I really wish you would like so
like
I just see these photos and they're so
beautiful they're just like so heavily
edited and they're almost blurry
wouldn't like they were taken around
like a 10,000 dollar cameras like it
doesn't make any sense I would just like
to know like what your thoughts are on
this whole cuz you're like a real artist
like you take pictures of like real
stuff and like your photos being like
manipulated like does that bother you
I mean and I speak for myself too like
you should have seen our emails back and
forth with these pictures for the nod I
was like make mention small or make
mention smaller no I don't need it
because I got my double chin when I
would by doctor sharing easy but back in
the day I was like Nick really smaller
make my way smaller make men's shoulders
no I make it bigger like everyone and I
do it too I'm guilty of it I wonder if
that offends you like it's your art no
what what about like presets which is
what we're all using out which is like
changing the exposure in the colors so
that so that's where like so if you ask
us to like edit stuff I don't know if I
manifest like well yeah so like or
anything like it's always like hey I
love this picture can you make a black
boy got it
what I feel like it gets a little weird
is when I find my stuff on Instagram and
it's been like put through 15,000 apps
on someone's iPhone dirty pirates map
yeah it's a whole new photo or like
their skin and like it just everything
and then that's annoying cuz like it
speaks for you yeah that makes it look
like we retouched it which we do we
don't use those apps so if someone like
doesn't say like I want to be retouch
are there just minimal things you do
before you send photos shine yeah like
everyone's like everyone's retouched
regardless even when they're not like
they are they are yes so it just I
thought the pictures from like my
engagement which was hard for me because
I didn't know I was getting each which
is the point you want to be surprised
but like my makeup was from so much
earlier that day like Zack and I are
kissing so like my lipstick is on him
and it's like in these photos which are
supposed to be like my most beautiful
photos I look like a big turd they're
never your most beautiful photos do you
find that most people do like a separate
engagement shoot afterwards we're like
they get their hair and makeup done yeah
cause like the proposal like you're
crying right there you're supposed to
not know did you know I had no I really
didn't know if you go look through the
pictures I should cut me off like
shaving on the way because I was wearing
the dress it was February was a really
nice day where they says like I put on a
dress I have to shave my legs
I cut myself I'm like oh I'll wipe it
off when I get to the restaurant there
was no restaurant so I really didn't
know and like I said one who loves
makeup like if you look at my makeup
that day you'll know I did not have it's
true yeah he was really excited no he's
like a great planner like he put so much
thought into everything you know
must be nice no
like I wish I had that look are you
married - shut up I didn't know that how
long you been engaged are you photograph
your own wedding
maybe so no how would you trust Barbara
and Juan who worked for you yeah both
lifetime okay yeah do you think you're
gonna have to pay them how does that
work I mean I hope not yet totally
fifteen years nobody's on dad okay would
you know when you're getting married no
interesting very interesting okay so
besides for Robert Herjavec and girl
with no job who are other some notable
weddings that you can share that you
were just there yeah like Kevin Jones
they're really sweet they seem like damn
like a nice marriage yeah that was out
there and we did People magazine with
them as well like totally like do you
find that like people when you do
weddings that are like a range with like
some sort of pressing like people like
forget to put photo credit Minh
over passed yeah we've learned from our
past like past mistakes more like
pictures have gone out yeah and then
it's like okay now the pictures already
run on Instagram let's say theoretically
for a day and then the tag goes in like
yeah so we've gotten much better about
controlling content and making sure that
pictures of creditor problem interesting
because that's how we hired a really
good one at quadrant one now you got a
you got a lawyer up photography's such a
co interesting wild business and then
with Instagram everyone thinks they're a
photographer so it's yes yes like we go
to a wedding and there's really like 350
photographers right taking pictures but
where the fog refers it's a little weird
now do you find it harder than like how
long have you been doing this
22 so do you find it harder now than
like 22 years ago to like get inside
like the dance circle and get a photo
cuz like everyone else is trying to like
on their phones get the same photo as
you and you got to be aggressive the
harder one is the aisle shot right so
when like brightest right now kiss boom
and then they walk down the aisle in it
everyone sticks their phone into the
middle of the aisle while you're walking
down the aisle dancing is not as bad
okay cuz and also chilling
for the most part brides aren't like oh
my god I have to have like a million -
right like the shot of you walking in
the eyes especially oh yeah we know but
now we have pictures that's so annoying
juber edit those out sometimes you can
do you prefer weddings or ceremonies
that are phoneless
yeah I love the hashtag unplugs meet you
yeah me too
yeah I was 30 it's important all about
unplug it's me I mean mine was like 45
but still it's important and it makes a
huge difference it just like the
ambience totally the few weddings I've
been to where people have phones up it's
so weird it feels like we're maybe they
had a collector yeah where it's like if
we're in like a synagogue or something
it's like you can't bring your phone
into shul right look like the sacred
sacrilegious I just want to live a
couple weeks ago I feel like they should
ban cellphones answer yeah no there's
just certain places it's like not
necessary but like I guess when I'm
gonna wedding and I'm bored I'm like oh
it wasn't my phone right now you know so
I kind of understand other people wanted
to do it no good but um okay so you're
going with Jackie to the State Fair one
house Jackie was inspired by Real
Housewives of Dallas Leeanne Locken who
got engaged at the State Fair and my man
is from Dallas and I want to pay tribute
to his home state even though there's
like nothing Texan about him and it's
really just me and we're just saying
about Tim were like you're the worst
person from Texas and I give me we have
a horse like come on you don't even have
an accent yeah so true all he does is
like randomly say weird [ __ ] like oh me
oh my totally he doesn't even have
cowboy boots useful I don't know whether
to have to have it there yeah yeah don't
worry yeah we're millionaires
how many wardrobe changes for me would
be too many like what's the what do you
think I shouldn't forget at the time we
really push okay I see you like three or
four I have some great looks what's your
vision Anthony it's got to be big
colorful like the Texas to the State
Fair
I think slogan was like everything's
bigger in Texas like everything we know
I think it's like me we need to go like
yeah me too do you get it to do a lot of
like fun engagement sheets like that or
am I just a whack job no this is like
well I mean Muslim in New York City this
is like we're gonna Dallas where is in
the city like the most creative plates
cheap-shot someone's like wedding or
engagement shooters it's like any photo
shoot I mean I'm all about I love urban
architecture select Rebecca me packing
okay yeah me packing Maya
so do you got her like a city setting
versus a country for cool people
regardless yeah so like I'll take like a
cool person in a barn over like a pain
in the city
yeah like a pétain in the ass yeah over
like a cool person in the barn I'm all
about yes I'll take cool over what makes
a couple or a bride or a model cool nice
yeah yeah just
yeah how much did you want to kill me on
our day in Lincoln Center it was
torturous day I wanted to kill you
and I like new shoes and I was just like
trying to like like 95 degrees it was
literally just the hottest day ever and
like I'd spent all day my makeup and it
was gone and that's times I got like no
I know but like we needed to get it done
yeah the ice wouldn't go to a whole
other level the melt ice cream cone
torture like general the hardest day
literally do you find actually that like
with the new like people are more
specific like they'll come to you and be
like they'll show you pictures from like
the [ __ ] they see on Instagram I like
want you to recreate it is that annoying
you're like I'll have people come in and
be like I wanted a furious wedding but
I'm not getting married at 42nd Street
right and I'm like wait and I'll be like
I just don't you know to photograph
outside in the city that with like the
the increase in trash like just being
everywhere literally just edit it out
see your before and after up like a
couple outside like what you had to do
to the background just like yeah yeah
you just like shoot around it but it was
heavily dirtier than usual yeah like
big-ass trash ever yes there's trash
everywhere oh my god my final question
for you
bridezilla wise like I think it was fine
um what is kind of like the the most
negative experience you've had with
someone like who is just like
overwhelmed and bridezilla like I want
to tell a story please
but like no I can't yeah that's that's
the thing is I can't do it for them no
but like in context look like them say
just be like really like just so big
yeah so big but I feel like even like
the smallest throwing shoes in the
bridal suite tell people that I did that
was so much like and almost like it the
makeup artist oh god oh sweet and I was
like wow you know and I was eating
cucumbers right right just chill it's
just like oh my god that's horrible
honestly hell hath no fury what does it
have I have so many good way to Bridals
scorned have me back on post
of course like when I retire I'm really
like and then we'll how your story
demold like digital yeah I've got to do
me as a bride yet I think I'm gonna be a
chill bride and I love them I think you
are gonna be a chill bread too and I'm
really like down for everything you know
so I said like a big arm but hopefully
by then like that won't even be a
possibility yeah you know hopefully
hopefully drop the dream okay so you
post premium content on Instagram how
many times a day we try to say like two
times times a day in stores where can
people follow follow you uh Anthony
busca photography on Instagram is where
we're gonna be the most active uh
Anthony Vasquez talking on Facebook
we've so many bridal toasters that I
really feel like this was helpful um
Thank You Anthony for being here thank
you toasters for just being alive
we are back tomorrow just Jackie and I
so make sure to watch the chest movie of
the week which is a room and we're also
be doing deer toasters which is it
advice segment email is dear toasters at
gmail.com if you have something
interesting you want us to speak on
thank you all so much for being here we
will see you tomorrow we're gonna do a
little photo shoot with it oh yeah
you